okay sona and i are in a valley outside
of garni in armenia and it's absolutely
stunning some of the most beautiful
countryside i've seen in my life Mount
Ararat is right over there
and those gentlemen right there are
sheep herders and I'm disappointed
because they're dressed like bouncers
that's not what I wanted to see I wanted
to see like the traditional Armenian the
big stick yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we need like a strategy because no one
has told us anything about how to herd
sheep all we know is that we're supposed
to kind of keep them in a certain area
yeah but we don't know what to do other
than that what do you think I think they
get scared when you get close to them
right um so maybe if you just like me
and in turns
I would think you're good at this
because you're very loud like in the
office I can hear you way down the
hallway you know you're loud right well
yeah I don't know if it's about volume
but you could be talking about anything
you'd be talking about your favorite TV
shows like the next season of The
Bachelor yeah okay
but I think what I think Ben each is
gonna be a great bachelor Ben H yeah
who's that
he's from Kaitlyn's season
let's go she off you go now what makes a
good bachelor a guy who's kind of a dick
yeah I'm not that much drama I mean what
does he just want out of that much drama
Shauna you're natural speaking voice is
driving them that way your brain hurt I
think that H is gonna fall in love a lot
with a lot of different people moaning
they're getting away from us I'll get
him hey you stop lollygaggin I think he
just felt for Kaitlyn really hard and I
think that he's gonna fall in love again
a lot I would enough about the bachelor
I just took a [ __ ]
[Applause]
you